consider the following
we have in the world by the the latest
count which is kept by uh forbes
magazine
they publish an issue uh once a year the
billionaires issue i'm a definitely a
billionaire's warrior i i want to know
who's on the list how many and so on
they're
2755 billionaires on the list this year
their combined
net worth their combined wealth of these
2
700 people
13.1 trillion dollars
whoa what 13.1
trillion
dollars so
think of it
one percent
of that
13.1 trillion so 10 is 1.3 trillion uh
and uh 10 of that is 130 billion so 1 of
their net worth is 130 billion dollars
that's basically what you need to get
every kid in school in the world to have
health care for everybody to have safe
water sanitation i feel like this is a
this is an ancient argument like tax the
rich and you know thomas piketty wrote
about it in capital and karl marx
certainly talked about it and like oh
and poverty
tax the rich if only the billionaires
would give up half of their billions or
whatever but isn't it a little more
complicated than that what do poor
people need now
to get out of poverty
not a lot they need electricity
they need connectivity and a device so
that they can listen to your show
because what are they going to do
otherwise
we are huge in sub-saharan africa we
need the poor to listen to metaphysical
milkshake and to buy from our sponsors
there you go and then they need
schools
and they need clinics and community
health workers
and i spend a you know i make my living
adding up how much all of that costs
and it's it's not a lot it's just more
than poor people can afford on their own